Manufacturing steel is one of the largest industrial sources of greenhouse gas emissions.
If it could be done in a carbon-free way,...
...it would revolutionize the industry and help fight climate change.
There's a company in Boston trying to do just that.
If we can cut greenhouse gas emissions from steel,...
...that's almost 10% of CO2 emissions.
That's worth going after.
No one's going to pay a premium for green metal.
It's got to be better, cleaner and cheaper.
Conventional process to make steel, it's a chemical reaction.
The blast of air goes in, passes over a form of carbon and converts to a carbon monoxide gas.
And that gas reduces the iron oxide to iron.
So, for every ton of iron you make, you make several tons of CO2.
You got iron oxide.
You dissolve that into a mix of other oxides.
And by that passage of electric current, the iron oxide is decomposed,...
...and it produces liquid iron.
The oxygen out of the iron oxide comes off as oxygen gas.
The production of C02 is zero.
The electricity can be produced sustainably without CO2 emissions.
In big industry, capital intensive, risk averse,...
...disruption in those industries does not come within the industry.
It comes outside the industry.
So, we're the disruptors.